we're told that a 10 liter cylinder
contains 7.60 grams of argon in gas form
and 4.40 grams of molecular nitrogen
once again in gas form at 25 degrees
celsius
calculate the partial pressure of each
gas and the total pressure in the
cylinder
alright so pause this video and see if
you can work through this on your own
before we work through it together
all right so you might imagine that the
ideal gas law is applicable here and
it's applicable whether we're just
thinking about the partial pressures of
each gas or the total so the ideal gas
law tells us that pressure times volume
is equal to the number of moles times
the ideal gas constant times temperature
and in this case we're trying to solve
for pressure whether it's partial
pressure or total pressure so to solve
for pressure here we can just divide
both sides by v and you get pressure is
equal to the number of moles times the
ideal gas constant times the temperature
divided by the volume
and so we can use this to figure out the
partial pressure of each of these gases
so we can say
that the partial pressure of argon is
going to be equal to the number of moles
of argon times the ideal gas constant
times the temperature both gases are at
the same temperature over here divided
by the volume and then we can also say
that the partial pressure of our
molecular nitrogen
is equal to the number of moles of our
molecular nitrogen times the ideal gas
constant times the temperature divided
by the volume
so we already know several of these
things we can look up the ideal gas
constant with the appropriate units over
here they've given us the temperature at
least in terms of degrees celsius we'll
have to convert that to kelvin and
they've also given us the volume so all
we really have to do is figure out the
number of moles of each of these and to
figure out the number of moles they give
us the mass we just have to think about
molar mass
so let's look up the molar mass of argon
as well as the molar mass of
molecular nitrogen
so the molar mass of argon getting out
our periodic table of elements we look
at argon right over here and it has an
average atomic mass of
39.95 which also gives us our molar mass
so a mole of argon will have a mass of
39.95
grams per mole
and then if we want to figure out the
same thing for our molecular nitrogen we
look up nitrogen here we see an average
atomic mass of
14.01 so we might be tempted to say that
the molar mass of molecular nitrogen is
14.01 grams per mole but we have to
remind ourselves that molecular nitrogen
is made up of two nitrogen atoms so the
molar mass is going to be twice this or
28.02
grams per mole so this is equal to 28.02
grams
per mole and then we can apply each of
these equations so the partial pressure
of argon let me give myself a little
extra space here
partial pressure of argon is going to be
equal to the number of moles of argon
well that's just going to be let me do
this in another color so you can see
this part of the calculation that's
going to be the grams of argon so let me
write that down 7.60
grams times 1 over the molar mass so
times
1 over 39.95
moles
per gram and you can see that the units
work out grams cancel with grams and
this is just going to give you the
number of moles of our argon and then we
multiply that times our ideal gas
constant and we have to pick which one
to use in this case we're dealing with
liters so both of these cases deal with
that and the difference between these is
how they deal with pressure the first is
in terms of atmospheres the second is in
terms of tor so if we want our partial
and total pressures in terms of tor we
could use this second one so let's do
that so in this case let's use this
second ideal gas constant so that's
going to be times 62.36
liter
poor
per
mole
kelvin
and then we need to multiply that times
the temperature so 25 degrees celsius in
kelvin we add
273 to that so that's 298
kelvin and all of that
is going to be divided by our volume
which is 10.0 liters 10.0 liters and we
can validate that the units work out we
already talked about these grams
cancelling out this mole cancels with
this mole
this kelvin cancels with that kelvin and
then this liters cancels with this
liters and we're just left with tor
which is what we care about we're
thinking about a pressure in this case a
partial pressure we have 7.60
divided by
39.95
times 62.36
times
298
divided by
10.0
is equal to this business and now we
just have to think about our significant
figures here so we have three here four
here three here and three here so when
we're multiplying and dividing we'll
just go to the fewest number of
significant figures we have so it's
three so we'll want to go around to 354
torr
so the partial pressure of argon 354
torr and now we can do the same thing
for the molecular nitrogen and let me
get myself a little more space here so
the partial pressure of our molecular
nitrogen is going to be equal to
i will do this in a different color as
well when i figure out the number of
moles that is going to be the mass of
molecular nitrogen which is
4.40 grams
times 1 over the molar mass so that's 1
over 28.02
grams per
mole
and then that is going to be times our
ideal gas constant so we can really just
copy the rest of this right over here
times 62.36
liter
torr
per
mole
kelvin times 298
kelvin all of that is going to be over
10.0
liters and once again the units work out
grams cancel with grams moles cancel
with moles liters with liters kelvin
with kelvin and we're just left with tor
and this gets us to
4.40
divided by 28.02
times 62 62.36
times 298 divided by
10.0 is equal to this and once again the
lowest significant figures we have here
are three so we'll arrive we'll round
this to 290
so this is equal to 292
torr
and so we've figured out the partial
pressure of each of these and if we want
to figure out the total pressure
the total pressure that's just going to
be the sum of the partial pressures
so it's going to be the partial pressure
of the argon plus the partial pressure
of the molecular nitrogen and so this is
going to be let's see i think i can do
this in my head
640
torr
and we are done